okay here we are again talking about
another classic movie from the 1980s
yeah now this one someone recommended
because Rutger Hauer recently passed
away yeah it was like why don't you do a
Rutger Hauer movie and since we've
already done Blade Runner the first one
I thought of was The Hitcher yeah I'm
glad you recommended this one Jenny
because I've never seen it yeah this
like this freaked me out because like I
told him about I'm like oh we have to do
that sure it's like so good and I
haven't seen it in such a long time and
he had like never even heard of it yeah
this was like spot-on I mean this is one
that I wish I would have known about
because it was like everything I like in
a movie I mean the moat for guys that
haven't seen it it's very much kind of
like a mixture of Mad Max 1 um it's kind
of like Mad Max 1 maybe like hills have
eyes and imagine Roy batty
you know from Blade Runner being the bad
guy and it's a cool flick man I liked it
Breck our hour is so scary yeah it was
there's not it's also kind of like
remember that what was it one like duel
yeah like duel also a lot of people have
compared it to duel is a very similar
story yeah and there's not a lot of
dialogue in a lot of it it's a very like
you said it's a very simple like
elemental story it came out in early
1986 and it was written by a guy named
Eric read now he had only as far as I
know he had only written like short
films before this but he actually got
the idea for the movie from the door
songwriters on the storm like he was
listening to it when I was in a road
trip and he was like man wouldn't that
make it like a great opening of a movie
just like some desolate yeah Road and
then he spent like he was living in
Texas at the time and he was like
driving a cab and so he wrote the
screenplay now the original version of
the screenplay was more than three hours
yeah yeah it's very simple story young
guy he's probably in his early 20s
um out in a desert out in Texas being
chased by a [ __ ] serial killer and
cops getting involved and he's taking
the rap for what the serial killers do
the cops think that he did it it's it's
wild it's pretty wild it also in a weird
way kind of reminds me of a Van Damme
movie in a way I don't know why there
was just something about it where that
kid could have been played by Van Damme
it's funny because I was looking at all
the actors that they considered for both
roles some of the actors they consider
for the C thomas Howell role it plays a
character named Jim Halsey were Tom
Cruise yeah okay which I don't know I
don't think that would have worked as
Tom Cruise is too cocky even when he was
young I don't think that would have come
off also Emilia Emilia s Emilio Estevez
Matthew Modine yeah
those kind of Matthew Modine probably
would have been good because I think the
reason that see thomas Howell worked so
well was because he's kind of a scrawny
kid he was clearly very young and you
could tell that he was like a
good-hearted dude but he wasn't he
didn't have like a lot of common sense
yeah
a naive yeah and he and he was like
rolled young and naive so I think that
really worked to the movie's advantage
now it should be noted that see Thomas
Howell
when he took this role like when he
first heard about it cuz like they sent
him the script and he was like man I
don't know if I want to do that it just
sounds like a generic thriller but then
they sent him the script and he thought
it was amazing and it's like I couldn't
put it down and then when he found at
the Rutger Hauer was gonna be the
villain he's like oh I really want to do
it now cuz I'm [ __ ] terrified like it
the actor I'm terrified
this is the best Rutger Hauer movie I've
seen where he starred in it I've seen
some of the other ones where he was
starring in it and there they tend to be
be movies like there was an alien ripoff
that I saw I don't remember what that
one was was someone recommended
Nighthawks to me of him being a villain
and I don't think I've seen that but to
be honest even when he's a good guy like
for example in ladyhawk he's still like
Superman icing like he's he seems like
he can't help himself he seemed psycho
he's just like this very like icy
[ __ ] I know why I reminded me of
of a Van Damme movie you know it in
certain parts in certain scenes it looks
like the scene where from Universal
Soldier where Van Damme was in out in
the desert in that in that okay I got in
the hotel yeah because there's a lot of
settings kind of like that I think
that's where I kind of got that flavor
but really reminds me of a Mad Max movie
yeah and what road warrior in Mad Max 1
well bind but it's not it seems
post-apocalyptic in the beginning
because you know there's dust storms and
stuff going on and you're not really
sure you know where the weary where this
is taking place you find out later is
Texas yeah I thought it was Mojave
Desert maybe yeah you can't release it
like he does say that he's I mean the
whole setup of the movie it's like all
he's doing is that he's from Chicago and
he is driving a car to San Diego and
what they called a drive away which is
like somebody that ordered a car and
they need like people to drive them to
the person that bought them I'm guessing
I think that's what that I don't know if
they don't think they do not any want to
do but um back in the day they did that
and he said like later on he said he'd
been on a list because he really wanted
to drive out to California and he wanted
to like get paid for doing it so it's
not his car he's like driving out I
think it's a Cadillac um I think I mean
that's what everything I said about it
but I couldn't remember I thought it was
a [ __ ] Chevy Cutlass when I yeah the
car he was driving off yeah I thought I
thought that was a Malibu classic yeah a
Chevy Malibu cause I don't know it's
like most of the reviews I said said it
was a Cadillac no I don't believe so
I don't I don't think it was no I felt
like I said I thought it was a Chevy
Cutlass but cuz my dad used to have one
that looked almost I think it like
Cutlass in the Malibu classic we're
about the same car they did they looks
various I think it was like different
shrimp act that's probably why something
like that wasn't an expensive car that
was just a regular I think it was like a
some model benek a car they would it
wasn't what didn't know they think
didn't didn't didn't Chevy make the cake
our I think our platform yes so so he's
basically driving from Chicago to San
Diego and you know he's he's getting
lonely like they show it
beginning like he's by himself he's
listening to the radio he's drinking
coffee trying to stay awake because I
guess he's trying to get a lot of hours
in and he's falling asleep he almost
gets hit by a truck so then like it
starts pouring down rain and he sees
this shadowy hitchhiker on the side of
the road and he doesn't he doesn't say
this now but you find out later he's
like well you know it was raining and I
felt bad for the guy and also I thought
that if I picked someone up to have
somebody to talk to you then they would
keep me awake and I could like drive
longer so it's not like he just he's
just an idiot anyway you know he just
felt bad for the guy cuz he couldn't
really see him because it was like dark
and everything and the funny thing is
that as soon as like Rutger Hauer like
pokes his little hat in the window Jim
Halsey says my mother told me never do
this let me get into it too far into it
if you haven't seen this movie you can
watch it for free on YouTube
yeah they had two versions of it up and
one the one version that we saw look
like 1080p look pretty good here's the
fucked-up thing it's like it seems like
one they don't have a blu-ray release in
the US the only country that has a
blu-ray release is Germany yeah and it's
expensive yeah and the DVD is rare the
DVD is I think they only released it in
Britain they have like a two-disc
special edition because I saw a couple
of other guys reviewing it and they had
the British like with the British rating
thing on the bottom and it comes with
two discs like it's got a bunch of extra
[ __ ] on it right but I think that's UK
only so I mean you can order it but only
if you have like a region-free player
which yeah I want it I want to look more
into it I want to own this movie I sure
would like a blu-ray releases but I'd
really like to have you think that now
that Rutger Howard is dead that somebody
would come I feel like maybe this will
happen because this is one of those
movies it's like movie it's so good and
it's like it's so it seems like it's
really underrated very underrated this
is much better than a lot of other
movies of its type for that time like I
don't know why I don't know I don't know
why I didn't know this movie I don't
know either that like freedom and they
didn't get a good release in the u.s. um
it did uh it got but it didn't do very
well like it kind of got it got kind of
like meta scathing reviews it didn't do
that great at the box office that only
made
like pretty much exactly its budget back
and that's it which you know that's
that's another to us um I don't really
get why people didn't it this is one of
those ones where it kind of came out it
came and went it seemed like people
didn't really want to see it critics
didn't really like it and then but then
like it sort of got new life like on VHS
and cable because I first saw it like a
year or two after it came out came out
in early 1986 I probably saw it in 87 or
88 when it came to HBO or whatever and I
think after that happened I think it
started to develop a cult following and
it's like now if you watch like all
these like horror movie reviewers and
stuff like that they're like what the
[ __ ] man this is like the most awesome
this is like one of the best horror
movies of the 80s even though some
people might not call it a horror movie
because it's quote/unquote it's usually
classified as like a thriller
or like an action movie but it is
totally oh yeah I would definitely call
it a horror movie yeah you know even
though I should say that the initial
screenplay
was like way way WAY gory er then it
ended up you know what I mean and the
only reason I that wrote the screenplay
Eric read he had all this [ __ ] in there
that was like there was all kind of like
[ __ ] like you got to see like a
person getting torn in half there was
like a eyeball and somebody's hamburger
there was like all this other kind of
like super super gory violence and the
studio wanted to make it more as a
thriller and not they're like well the
way it reads now it's like a slasher
like we like it but we'll let's tone the
violence down and in a way I think that
worked to its advantage yeah it is a
very violent movie yeah but a lot of the
violence happens off screen and I think
that that makes it better it makes it
like more suspenseful this is almost for
real like a [ __ ] Hitchcock movie yeah
you know what I mean it on it it's much
more fast-paced in that than Hitchin it
is but in the sense of like particularly
in the in the sense of like John Rider
the hitch-hiker kind of framing Jim
Halsey for all of his murders that's a
very Hitchcock if you like 80s horror or
80s action you
like the movie yeah I liked it it also
had you know for for any gun buffs out
there that had cool 80s guns
the cops are Carrie and Smith and
Wesson's snub-nosed revolvers
look like one of them look like it's
numb those 41 Magnum and then of course
it at the end the ubiquitous Franchi
spas-12 makes an appearance Rutger
Howard with a spas-12 and you know it
which is a which is a badass iconic
shotguns the same one that terminator
have from Terminator 1 and neat me
shotgun you know this kind of had a
menacing look and you see right Rutger
Howard using one pretty neat they always
had the damn armrest on that thing turn
weird you know it's guys who know what
if the spas-12 is is know that I'm
talking about they had a little hook it
was kind of like a carrying handle on
the damn folding stock and you could
twist it around and make it an arm brace
you could fire one handed that's how I
was doing that in Terminator 1 yeah a
little hook but yeah it makes an
appearance I was gonna say when you were
talking about this being similar to Mad
Max I was like did you know that the guy
who shot this the cinematographer John
seal would later go on to be nominated
for an Oscar for guess what Mad Max fury
road that was the same cinematographer
yeah there's desert car chases and
desert car wrecks in it not quite as
much as a you know it's like a George
Miller film but but it's pretty good on
homage yeah I mean like particularly the
one seen near the end were like record
how're like shoots out the [ __ ]
helicopter and it like crashes like
blows and these [ __ ] police cars gone
flying and [ __ ] like that yeah and it's
like it's it's a very mad max type of
thing and it looks like they did that
[ __ ] for real and they probably did yeah
86 Rutger Howard
shoots down a helicopter with a [ __ ]
37 magnum revolver that Freddie got off
a cop and I made it they filmed it the
way it make it look like maybe it could
happen the range is probably about 75
yards 75 meters and he shot the damn
engine of the helicopter that crashed
and of course when it crashes crashes on
the road and a car hits it it's pretty
cool yeah I mean you have to think and
and I'm gonna kind of go into this a
little bit like I said if you haven't
seen this movie go watch it a couple
people toast it for free on YouTube
because I didn't
realize but it's like kind of hard to
get because I was thinking oh they'd
have a blu-ray and [ __ ] like that yeah
they do not unless you're in Germany so
I was kind of upset but then I was like
well can we even rent it can we just
like the only way you can roof is rent
is like the [ __ ] 2000 remake which I
haven't seen it's the same writer like
Eric read birth the screenplay for the
remake - and I love Sean Bean the guy
that's in it but I've heard it was
terrible
I've heard that they made it like into a
straight-up slasher movie which is what
kind of Eric red wanted to start with
but I think it's better that they didn't
go in that direction because like I said
they made it as super violent and it's
kind of gory but they don't show a lot
of the stuff like I said spoiler alert
when Jennifer Jason Leigh gets torn in
half at the end but they don't show it
but the noise is bad enough like the
sound effect is valid because it leaves
it to your imagination you're like oh
yeah I could imagine that happen now the
remake I've never seen it so I've notice
I haven't seen it I've heard it's bad
but you know we just heard that yeah so
you know I'm willing to give it a chance
maybe but you know I mean if they you
know depends on yeah that's some people
don't like a lot of movies that I like
but I'm pissed that I can't get this on
blu-ray I wanna [ __ ] it's just like it
amazed me because okay now people that
grew up in the 80s and especially if you
had HBO Cinemax [ __ ] like that like I
did when I was a teenager it's like this
seems like it was in pretty heavy
rotation because I saw it like a bunch
of times like in the mid to late 80s and
so I feel like and I feel like it has
like a pretty big cult following so I
thought it would be super easy like when
we went to go buy a copy of it I thought
it would be easy to get it's really not
and I think that's very very weird it
seems like it slipped through the cracks
that company that did that released a
blu-ray of Dagon that you bought for me
would you would think they'd be a would
be an excellent company to probably
release yeah so why doesn't like shout
factory or arrow or somebody like that
well arrow I guess they do that's that's
UK I think I got a feeling now that
Rutgers gone you'll probably start
seeing that I feel like that too because
they'll probably like re-release a lot
of his back catalogue but you know what
I mean okay so what I wanted to get into
a little bit because we were talking
about this who watched the movie now
there are something like I said this
whole movie there's dialogue in it but
not a lot it's basically just like a
really long like cat-and-mouse game
between this crazy psychopathic
hitchhiker and this poor kid who just
gets who did a good deed and then you
know yeah no good deed goes unpunished
they say now this character is basically
Roy paddy I mean you couldn't you know
it's it's it's Rutger doing Roy batty
basically so if you like that character
you'll like this one I mean as soon as
he gets in the car like this movie like
seriously does not [ __ ] around it's like
there's a couple minutes of like see
Thomas howl like driving and drinking
coffee and then he almost like he falls
asleep and he almost hits a truck then a
couple minutes later he picks [ __ ]
Rutger Hauer up and one of the first
things Rutger Hauer says there's like
there's some little small talk and like
Jim Halsey is like asking him some
questions and he won't he's very evasive
and like he won't really answer them
and then he says something like they
passed this other car like this little
VW Beetle and that you know like the
hitchhiker just like puts his [ __ ]
foot on the gas and it's like speeds
passing and he's like what the [ __ ] man
and he's like you know and he it's like
the people that run the car he's like
yeah I cut off his legs and his arms and
his head and I'm gonna do the same to
you
you know what I mean and I was like oh
[ __ ] now it's on and the thing is it's
like you think you know because Jim
Halsey at some point like a few minutes
later he's understandably like freaking
the [ __ ] out and this guy's like
threatening with a knife and stuff like
that sort of you know he pushes him out
of the car and then you think he got
away but then this dude is just like
rillette he's like a [ __ ] terminator
man it's just like he keeps coming now
some people have said because there's
some stuff that let's say it's strains
credulity okay it's like you know how
does this guy know where Jim Halsey is
all the time how does how did he get in
that hotel room like how did he find the
hotel room had to get in there when the
door was locked
how did he get into that like police
station and like kill all those cops
without getting killed and stuff like
that see my theory and
her how're backed me up on this was that
he's not he's a dude but he's an
allegory for evil you know what I mean I
cuz I kind of get the feeling that yeah
he's a guy he can be hurt and killed
because you know he does get like hit by
a car and he's kind of [ __ ] up and he
does get shot and apparently dies at the
end but I feel like there's a
supernatural element says character I
feel like he's like the High Plains
Drifter or he's like Anton [ __ ] in No
Country for Old Men where it's like he
was a real guy but he was also a
representation of something of evil or a
representation of fate and I think that
he's there too
because one of the first things that he
says to Jim Halsey because she was he's
like what do you want from me what do
you want from me the first thing he says
is I want you to stop me you know what I
mean so I feel like this is just like I
don't want to say he's like a demon cuz
he's obviously not you know like I said
he gets hurt he's obviously a human but
I think he's like a representation of
something greater this is almost that
this is a very job like story
well it's inspired from riders on the
storm if you know the universe so he's
gonna be a dreamlike character a
character symbolizing what this guy
imagined the rider on a storm from a Jim
Morrison song was yeah so that's because
he comes from nowhere he's just like on
the side of the road he turns up at
places that like you'd be like how did
he get there how did he get there ahead
of him and he could have killed Jim
Halsey at any point but he's like toying
with him it's almost like he's grooming
him because he wants Jim Halsey to be
the one to kill him you know what I mean
so I kind of feel like there's that
whole thing going on and like I said you
know I was like sitting there watching
it because I hadn't seen it in a long
time the ohlet's I saw it like back on
cable like back in the day and the only
thing I remembered was the two scenes
that everybody remembers one the finger
in the French fries and to Jennifer
Jason Leigh getting pulled in half so
that was almost all I remembered and I
didn't even remember the whole
Rutger Hauer like setting you know see
Thomas Howells character up is like the
murder I didn't even remember any of
that aspect of it so I kind of thought
well maybe I'm just create like maybe
I'm reading into it too much but then
when I have like we started reading a
whole bunch of other reviews a lot of
people were making in fact multiple
people made the No Country for Old Men
reference which is something that I
thought of as well cuz I'm like that's a
very similar type of character and maybe
that's where the Coen brothers got the
idea also a couple people made reference
to High Plains Drifter because that guy
is like a guy but he's also like has a
supernatural he's like a representation
of he's more ghosts though yeah revenue
yeah yeah but I I definitely feel like
he has a supernatural aspect to him even
though he's in human form because he
does [ __ ] that a regular human can't do
you know what I mean he does like some
Jason Voorhees [ __ ] yeah like showing up
in places that he probably couldn't be
or how did he know where he was and all
this other kind of stuff he doesn't like
have any motivation you only hear his
name at the beginning like he tells Jim
palsies character his name John Ryder
very haltingly but then you don't know
his name right honest one yeah you don't
know his like motivation or nothing it
just seems like he's doing this just for
shits and giggles and then you get like
to the very very end of the movie when
the cops have him in custody and he
won't tell them anything he has no idea
ID he won't tell them his name and he
just like won't talk to them and I'm
kind of thinking that they're trying to
imply that he's not a ghost but like not
entirely a human person like a demon or
something
yeah like or he's like a representation
of something else I'm like I said Rutger
Hauer said the exact same thing when he
was doing this role and he was kind of
upset that that a lot of critics didn't
really like this movie and he was like
because he had got kind of sick of
playing villains and he wasn't gonna
play any more villains but then he got
this screenplay and he's like okay well
I'll play one more villain gonna play
this one cuz this casts so he wanted to
do this and he was kind of disappointed
that the movie like really didn't do her
it was pretty much a lot I don't
understand why it didn't I don't really
know that either it was like
I'd like action it was it was super
suspenseful was this a Hollywood movie
um it was a smaller studio but yeah it
makes me think there was some
behind-the-scenes Hollywood cannery
going on probably to step on this there
may have been this may have been
competition for something else that was
out the theater at the time and you know
I mean they didn't they did what they
could to make sure that the word did not
get out on this one maybe it was made by
HBO Pictures and I think I believed at
the time that if HBO pictures they had a
deal with Tristar pictures that
everything that HBO pictures made
Tristar had to distribute it so they had
that whole thing going some kind of
politics and HBO pictures like the guy
who was like the CEO or the vice person
or whatever he said that The Hitcher was
like their best movie of that year and
he was like super hyped about it and
then like it really didn't do very well
and like I said most critics gave it a
[ __ ] you know they just ravaged the
[ __ ] yeah probably paid to because well
I it's just the thing is a lot of them
didn't like it because they thought it
was very nice t'k some of them didn't
like it because it was too violent some
didn't like it because it was not
violent enough there was like the you
know maybe they should have shown more
of the violence because some people were
like disappointed because I think they
wanted like more of a slasher type movie
um
some critics didn't I did like it but
not a lot of them um so it's just it's
one of those ones you know and I was
watching this [ __ ] video like one of
this this channel I liked it's two Brits
that are always talking about like
horror movies and scary [ __ ] top 5 scary
and they did a show about the top 5
brilliant horror movies that were [ __ ]
on by critics when they came out and
it's just like it's amazing how many I
mean the critics get it right a lot of
the time too but it's amazing like in
the case of like the thing or The
Shining or something like that to go
back and read some reviews about those
movies when they first came out and it's
like gee you know knowing now that
there's like [ __ ] classics and it's
just hilarious to me that they just got
it so so wrong and I think they really
got it wrong in this case too because to
me this seems like one I mean one of the
best horror movies of
80s for sure certainly one of the most
liked tense thrillers of the 80s I mean
it really like made a big impression on
me when I saw it I don't know I'm not
gonna say it's one of the best of the
eighties but maybe one of the best of
the late 80s yeah yeah I mean I would
think that it would do pretty good for
the year that it came out cuz there's
just there's a lot of good stuff that
came out during that decade I mean this
was a good movie it wasn't that good
though I don't think I wouldn't put it
up there with like you know alien or
alien 2 or you know like aliens and well
yeah I mean well I said it wasn't one I
said I want to put it up that far but it
is a good move I mean very few movies
are as good as aliens right yeah there
was a lot of stuff that came out in that
decade this was this was a decent movie
though yeah I don't see what the problem
and like I said I feel like this is one
that it seems like it kind of slipped
through the cracks which is very good I
think it was a much in between stuff
some people didn't think you know I mean
some people didn't like because it
wasn't gory enough or it was too gory
they sort of fell into a bunch of
in-between stuff I also probably think
there might have been like I said maybe
some shaky Nury going on with the
studio's you know to kind of pull
attention away from this one and more
towards another movie that was playing
at the same time yeah that may have
happened and I don't know what came out
the same time you didn't have good
promotional tour before that a ban came
out so the average person didn't know
much about it
it also could have been that the average
moviegoer of that time was interested in
other kinds of movies because movies go
in and out of style yeah you know so it
might have been something like that
maybe it might have been the time of the
year too because it came out like in
February and that's traditionally that's
not a great time for Musa
I mean January and February that's where
Studios kind of like put all their [ __ ]
that they don't think is gonna do that
well you know what I mean another thing
that I remember from the late eighties
is that people's expectations were super
high fro cuz there was a long string of
[ __ ] really good movies for about a
decade and it could be that there was
kind of like market fatigue in a certain
way or the audience's have become more
jaded I mean this isn't a real high tech
spectacular stuff and some of the stuff
was shot pretty well
but we're not talking about t1 yeah
we're not talking about you know aliens
you know when it is it is not that it's
not a big-budget movie to me it felt a
lot like road warrior or Mad Max war
like in that budget air you know like in
that level still pretty good it's just
it was you know that particular audience
would like but in those two movies
actually I don't think really did all
that well upon release either that's
what I mean it so it's really hard to
judge because some things kind of are
kind of ahead of their time yeah
or people don't appreciate them at the
time but then like later that that's why
I think it's good to like do like a
reassessment because sometimes you saw
stuff like back in the day and you
remembered it not be but a lot of times
like when I watch movies again like this
movie I probably hadn't seen this for
maybe 20 years and when I saw it again I
was like amazed as like that was so it
was so much better than I remembered
because like I said those two scenes
made a big impression but I didn't
remember a lot of the rest of the story
had this come out maybe like in 83 or 84
I think it would have got a lot more
attention now some people I was reading
one review that said and I and I
actually agree with this they're like if
this had been like directed by Sam
Peckinpah and came out in the 70s people
would have been all over this yeah
because a lot of his movies were this
kind of Toad were very nihilistic like
that were like these horrible things
happen to people and you know the way
that Jim Halsey is character basically
has to he doesn't want to kill people he
doesn't want to do this and that but
it's see it almost seems like Rutger
Hauer is characters like making him do
it he's like I you know I want you to
stop me I'm you know and he's like
forcing him into doing that yeah and you
know the fact of him like Jennifer Jason
Leigh's character getting killed that
was like a huge failure on his part
because he could have he had so many
chances to kill Rutger Howard's
character before that and didn't take
them and they're just kind of showing
how you know hit his like weakness in
that department like you know not taking
him out when he had the chance to then
that ended up costing her life now that
was another thing to that
when the when this was being like
shopped around and you know blah blah
and like made and everything the
executives really did not want Jennifer
Jason Leigh's character whose name is
Nash they'd really did not want her to
die at the end um they're like or if she
does die can we at least have a funeral
or something so it's not quite so
horrific but yeah I think even Rutger
Hauer was a little bit like man that's
[ __ ] up
but the director Robert Harmon was like
yeah but he's like the baddest bad guy
ever like so he has to do this [ __ ] and
like not feel bad about it so they ended
up leaving it in although as I said you
know initially in the initial version of
the script they were going to show it
and I think in the remake they did show
it and I heard that it was like crappy
looking because it was like CGI but they
actually went there and they showed all
the [ __ ] and everything and like I said
I think it's better suggested I mean you
just see her screaming you see her hands
like straining against the ropes and
stuff and then they cut away really
quick and then there's just a horrible
sickening noise I want to see the movie
again I just wish that it was in you
know theater quality 1080p I don't think
yeah I think it was 1080p coming off of
probably like a bad DVD copy of it
that's what's on YouTube for free but I
would like to have a [ __ ] blu-ray
release I don't know what it looked like
in the theater like I said I can't
really afford to order the one from
Germany so I'm kind of hoping that some
like a shout factory hey yeah why don't
you why don't you guys release it
Germany actually might not play on one
of our play on a player yeah I don't
know like your if we usually play them
on the Xbox a UK release usually will I
mean I'm pretty I'm pretty sure the Xbox
might be region free I don't know and if
it's region free then I'll play anything
from anywhere around them I would just
hate me they want 50 something bucks for
that that's what I mean I was amazed and
then the DVDs aren't cheap either you
talk about $30 for an old dvn it's not
not even in widescreen cuz like I said I
don't even think I've do you know and
correct me if I'm wrong but I don't even
think there's been a u.s. DVD release
like the the two-disc special edition
one that's UK right and like I said the
only country that has blu-rays Germany
so
I don't know it's a rare movie I guess
and it's like I didn't even think that
because honestly when we were talking
about Recker Hauer and somebody said oh
he just passed away and you guys should
do a Rutger Hauer movie the first thing
I thought like after Blade Runner the
first thing I thought it was theater
yeah and it's like the one where he was
hunting the alien down in the future the
alien down in the future yeah
but it looks pretty [ __ ] wacky you
know I mean I remember seeing it a long
time ago and I saw yeah I saw a long
time ago wasn't impressed
and then somebody showed some scenes
from it which reminded me of that [ __ ]
it was like that I wouldn't mind seeing
that one again either the tone was to
tell and I remember was kind of like
Robocop you know mean [ __ ] inside but
if I did it was probably only once in it
over-the-top [ __ ] yeah
like I said the only other movie that
like really stood out was that Rutger
Hauer was in like others like The
Hitcher was the first one I thought of
but then I thought of like a lady hawk
but that's not you know that's a fantasy
like love story yeah it's uh I liked it
but um good I couldn't stand it I liked
it but like I said you know I hate to
say this wrote about poor Rutger Hauer
but he makes a better villain because
like even like I said when he's a good
guy in this movie he's super scary he
was just he just comes off as like very
menacing like and I guess he can't
really help it you know what I mean
that's the way he is I don't like the
sword and sandal fantasy it depends on
what it is I love owning I can do a code
a but I love ladyhawk when it came out I
think I like it less now than I did when
I was a teenager but I still really like
it a lot it's you know it's a cool story
you get to see a [ __ ] Bishop run
through the sword so that's that's
always nice but yeah so seriously if you
like before anybody takes it down if you
can't afford to buy The Hitcher or you
don't have it for some reason there's
actually a fairly decent there's a
couple fairly decent copies of it that
someone has uploaded to YouTube yeah um
it actually the one that we watched it
looks like it came from the DVD it's a
little like stretchy like it looks like
they stretched it a little bit you have
to fit the new screen but it's not like
super noticeable it doesn't really
bother me it's a little hazy because the
definition isn't that good but yeah but
it didn't for free you know it looked so
much better because I was only used to
seeing it on like HBO and VHS and [ __ ]
like that so I was actually surprised
it's like oh this is like a beautiful
looking movie like
[ __ ] vistas of like you know Texas
and [ __ ] like that it's like it looks
[ __ ] great like I said it looks very
much like a Mad Max type of movie really
nice cinematography yeah oh and the
score yeah it's fantastic yeah I love
this I got a feeling that a blu-ray
remaster would look [ __ ] awesome oh
yeah I feel like if they clean this up
because even I even said to you when we
were watching it I was like man that's I
remember seeing this in it looking
really like muddy and horrible and
apparently it did at the time too
because some critics complained about
that they said it's so dark and it's
like muddy and it looks like [ __ ] and
but when I saw the you know the DVD
quality one I was like wow this is a
really nice-looking movie and then you
know then I found out it was the same
guy that yeah there was that one scene
that he's going through that abandoned
service station yeah like garage it's
like a garage and it's dark in there but
then there's light beaming in through
the damn windows and all the dust is a
[ __ ] cool shot look like some
straight at a Blade Runner yeah
everything was like everything was good
in this and even like the way the guy
used the camera he did like a really
cool juxtaposition between these big
wide like vistas of like nothing does
and then like super super tight
close-ups of like people's faces so it
was like this look kind of oppressive
thing and then there was like this big
thing it's like hey there's nobody
around to help you and I also really
liked like the one scene where where
John Ryder goes in like it kills all the
cops and then like he let's see Thomas
Hollis character out of the jail cell
and then like gets the [ __ ] out of there
like a [ __ ] spooky ass ghost and [ __ ]
and then there's that great scene of
like see Thomas how like walking down
the hall super super slowly and then
that dog comes across the end of the
hallway and just like looks at him and
then kind of goes over there and it's
like super super slow and he's going to
go to the dogs like Ethan the [ __ ]
one of the dead calves just it's like
it's it's such a such a good movie and I
just feel like I wish I had seen it back
in the day because I know I kind of wish
you had to that way I could feel
nostalgia for what I'm seeing it but I'm
feeling nostalgia for it because you
never saw because I never saw it before
one thing I did feel nostalgia for was
all those interior shots yeah
the way restaurants used to look yeah
like you know
some way that restaurant look at the
inside when Denny's used to look [ __ ] I
remember that [ __ ] used to look really
[ __ ] cheap did it's like now that was
I she didn't I didn't know any better at
the time but it's like now when you see
movies yeah from back then I was like
man I think crap I can't believe I ate
in a place it look like everything had
that horrible like cheap ass [ __ ]
vinyl and [ __ ] what that that like funny
would that faux wood it was awful I
think some from the old Soviet Union
like everything was like brown it was
like [ __ ] what I don't know what the
hell were we thinking and then the car
interiors on all those old cars yeah
yeah cuz my stepdad had that car yeah it
was a Malibu classic
my dad had one like that but I had those
fat Leonard interiors yeah yeah it's
weird to see all that stuff now was it
that movie or was I watching cuz I was
watching a couple other movies from the
80s and I remember seeing like a couple
of macrame owls it might have been it
might have been that might have been I'm
cuz I was watching um chopping ball yeah
the other night or that was another
doing chopping MA was good
shudder just added that like yeah like a
couple days ago so I was like super
excited given a free plug shudder yeah
and Barbara Crampton is in it I thought
she was in there yeah she's cute and I
was so I was watching Andy's in that
movie if you guys want to see small
eighties titties are up there it's nice
robot killer robots that are straight
out of [ __ ] terminator whatever
though hunter-killer things look like a
giant tank
they look like they're smaller they kind
of look like Johnny Five yeah from short
circuit if ya blow a girl's head off a
[ __ ] 30 meters but they can't shoot a
dude who's standing up 10 feet from it's
just like a ridiculous there are really
terrible shots with those lasers too
yeah unless unless it's convenient I'll
go that one girl that got her head blown
up I think I laughed so hard at that
shot guy cuz I've forgotten about that
movie and I wasn't expecting yes like
correct shopping mall also fit in with
like you know like the Danville [ __ ]
dead mall seen it yeah because the whole
thing was shot and the whole thing was
shot the mall that had that same [ __ ]
mall feeling and from the from the mall
culture you know cuz you can tell just
like George Romero got like the
permission to film in the [ __ ]
Monroeville
or whatever it's like they got
permission to film every night at this
one mall they lost shopping mall was a
lot better than I expected it even
though not a lot of chopping mostly
lasering and choosing an idea or
lasering yeah laser attack by robots
robots with lasers where does that we
were talking about that because for some
reason they've been back in the 50s like
sci-fi movies lasers and robots
yeah because I was I was watching time
travelers on the mst3k and I was like
lasers yeah yeah so I couldn't remember
like cuz I watched shopping mall and
then I also watched night brain Elm
Street three dream warriors and I was
like so I remember like from the last
couple nights like seeing some macrame
owls cuz I remember my mom used to make
those and she taught me to make them to
when I was little but I don't remember
it might have been it might have been in
The Hitcher that I saw the macker males
anybody our males the little beads for
eyes go ahead and watch a movie watch it
for free you'll enjoy it yeah just go
watch it now before anybody like takes
it down because I think there's at least
two people that have it like I said if
you want to watch the remake that's up
to you man but it's like I don't know if
I want to waste my time watching it
because I've heard it was wrong well
we're not reviewing the remake but in
the original yeah you know there was
there was a sequel to this too oh yeah I
see to make a sequel this [ __ ] that's
what I mean it's a one-off right so it's
like that's what I mean I think this guy
is like not really a real person yeah
but I don't think Rutger Hauer was in
the second one but see thomas Howell was
okay so now I'm kind of curious what
happened in the second one like what
happened in the second one what could
possibly have happened
I don't know now okay now I got to go
watching [ __ ] all right I'm gonna go
watch the sequel okay all right so like
I said go check this out on YouTube and
we hope you have enjoyed our rambling
breakdown of it remember like share
subscribe good at patreon all that other
good stuff and we will see you next time